good morning Hank it's Tuesday today I
want to help you understand what's going
on in Syria and I know that you're on
the internet so you're constantly being
distracted by like photographs of Ryan
Gosling and homoerotic Sherlock
watercolors but just give me four
minutes okay so our story begins in 1946
with Syria declaring independence and
getting the flag Syria was briefly a
parliamentary republic but it never
really took it in the first ten years
they had four different constitutions
and like a gajillion changes in
government they were led by this guy and
this guy and this guy and this guy
couple important things first in 1956
Syria signed a pact with the Soviet
Union promising to dabble in communism
in exchange for guns and tanks and stuff
also in 1958 Syria and Egypt briefly
decided to become the same country the
United Arab Republic which of course
necessitated a new flag but then in 1961
Syria was like we're succeeding and
we're going back to our old flag this
led to a big mess in a couple coos
culminating with the bath party taking
control in 1963 with a new flag Hank you
may remember the bath party from Iraq
bathroom is a secular that is
non-religious political philosophy that
advocates for a socialist pan-arab
staked bath means Renaissance the idea
was that all the Arabs would unify and
have this awesome utopia it didn't work
all right let's get back to 1970 when
heretofore defense minister who Fez al
Assad becomes president of Syria by a
bloodless coup which is my favorite kind
of coup Hafez al-assad really oversaw
the first stable period in Syrian
history he passed a constitution he
established a state-run economy that led
to significant growth in per capita GDP
he also killed a lot of dissidents
disastrously invaded Israel in 1973 and
in 1976 entered the Lebanese civil war
first on one side then on the other
thereby beginning a Syrian occupation of
Lebanon that would last for almost
thirty years that occupation was not
popular particularly since Syria had a
habit of assassinating Lebanese
politicians also he changed the flag
twice once in 1972 and then again in
1980 one more thing about the Fez al
Assad he was a law we allow ISM as a
sect of she is amid some very unusual
beliefs for instance unlike most Muslims
they don't believe that praying 5 times
a day is mandatory and also unlike most
Muslims they celebrate Christmas
Hassan tried to wriggle all wisdom into
the Islamic mainstream for instance he
prayed in public and he built a lot of
mosques but still too a lot of Sunni and
even Shia Muslims Allah widths are seen
as apostates ok so in 2000 who Fez Ellis
had died and the Syrian Parliament
immediately passed a law reducing the
minimum age for president from 42
34 you'll never guess who was 34 at the
time unless you guess it was a Lawson
son Bashar so Bashar al-asad is
immediately elected president of Syria
with ninety seven point nine percent of
the vote a statistic that is slightly
less impressive when you consider that
no one else was allowed on the ballot
and there is widespread hope that Bashar
al-assad will bring reform not so much
that said no one foresaw how he would
respond to the pro-democracy Arab Spring
protests that began in early 2011
soldiers who refused to fire on
civilians were summarily executed entire
towns were bombed torture was widespread
tens of thousands were arrested the UN
estimates that in the last year more
than 10,000 people most of them unarmed
civilians have been killed in Syria and
Hank while this fight is definitely not
about religion it's important to
understand that most of the
pro-democracy opposition is Sunni Muslim
and that Assad still enjoys significant
support among many allow ease and
Christians and now Syria finds itself in
a civil war the UN Security Council has
tried to act on this but both Russia and
China have vetoed all resolutions about
Syria possibly because of like old Cold
War ties possibly because what they see
has failed intervention in Libya and
possibly because Russia's only naval
port in the Middle East is in Syria so
at the moment violence continues and
there is no clear path forward like
Syria has been expelled from the Arab
League and sanctions will drag down the
Syrian economy but will any of that
force al Assad to resign and if he does
can Syria return to stability or will it
again find itself having like three coos
a year it's worth remembering that the
pro-democracy opposition's flag is this
the one that flew over Syria during all
its coos and instability but those
people want freedom and representative
government and the Syrian regime is
massacring them for it so should we help
and if so how those are rhetorical
questions let's continue the
conversation in comments Hank I'll see
you on Friday